كمان كمان
[تصفيق]
2024 لكن الطريقه لذلك صعبه في ظل منافسه
قويه من داخل الحزب الجمهوريه مع سطوع نجم
حاكم فلوريدا روند سانتوس وانعكاسي نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه التي وصفت بالضعيفه
وملفات قضائيه تواجه ترامب
هناك نجوم صعيدون منهم
حيث خسر مرشحوه واكتشف الجمهوريون انه كان
يجمع الاموال الظاهريا لمرشحين اخرين لكنه
ينفقه على نفسه
كما ان انتقاداتي بعض الجمهوريين ترامب
ومطالبه بعضهم بالمضي قدما بعيدا عنه تشير
الى انقسام داخل الحزب حوله ما يعني انه
قد لا يحظى بدعم كل الجمهوريين
وهو معروف وارقامهم مؤيديه ليست مرتفعه
هناك ثلاثيه الرابحه ضده بالفعل لكن في
الوقت نفسه هناك الكثير من الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين قد يكون بشان ما يعني ذلك
بالنسبه للبلد
دياك شكرا
عنه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز من ان مستشارينا
لاداره بايدا يعملون على استراتيجيه
لكيفيه رد البيت الابيض على هجماته على
الاداره والتي كانت واضحه في خطاب اعلان
الترشح
ترشح ترامب الان يختلفوا عن مكانها عليه
عام 2015 ففي ذلك الوقت كان ينظر اليه كان
رجل اعمال ونجمه تلفزيونيه اعطوا وعودا
كثيره لاصلاح ما وصفه انذاك بالفساد اما
الان فهو رئيس سابق يواجه ملاحقات قانونيه
الحسين الطاوض العربيه